et maintenant
merci serge raffy
c'est un jeu rapide bonsoir bonsoir vous
avez 50 ans où était rédacteur en chef
du magazine elle rédacteur en chef
adjoint du nouvel observateur
aujourd'hui vous êtes journaliste
indépendant écrivain auteur entre autres
de jospin secrets de famille chez fayard
est votre dernier bouquin toujours chez
fayard s'appelle castro l'infidèle
il a déjà donné lieu à de nombreuses
traductions alors quand on dit mais
comment tu te commencer ton émission le
samedi soir avec un écrivain peu connue
sans doute bon journalisme est mais qui
n'est pas connu du grand public jeudi
parce que votre livre est très étonnant
et qui mérite serge raffy la une de
cette émission
en des plumes dans le premier stage
raffy une vie de castro plein de folie
et de sang qui aurait pu être écrite par
gabriel garcia marquez l'auteur de cent
ans de solitude
ils voient sans doute en castro un
personnage un petit peu à la lafa le
staff enfin quelque chose d'un petit peu
hors du commun quoi c'est ça qui
l'intéressent la limite c'est la
personnalité de castro castro c'est un
personnage shakespearien way qui en même
temps désagréable parce qu'on est un
tyran est un dictateur et en même temps
qui fascine parce qu'il a lille est au
pouvoir depuis quarante cinq ans c'est
quand même surréaliste
et puis surtout parce que il a envoûté
des tas de gens moi le premier
d'ailleurs justement vous vous êtes un
envoûté des années 70 ça vous venez du
pc au départ et un jour vous allez faire
serge raffy un voyage enquête à cuba
vous rencontrer des dissidents et vous
apprenez à votre retour en france que
ces dissidents ben finalement ils ont
été inquiétés parce que vous avez
rencontrées et là ça commence à vous
mettre la puce à l'oreille
bah oui vous rencontrer des gens et puis
c'est ces gens vous considériez un peu
comme des amis se retrouvent en prison
un peu à cause de vous c'est à dire
j'avais l'impression que j'étais
responsable puisque il m'avait
rencontrés ils se retrouvaient un peu
comme des agents de l'étranger dans à
cuba et en prison donc tout d'un coup ma
posture vis-à-vis de ce pays a un peu
changé je me suis dit mais finalement
c'est pas c'est pas aussi simple parade
c'est pas la carte postale les caraïbes
ce que j'appelle le tropisme du palmier
c'est autre chose c'est autre chose
alors on va parler de castro vous fait
des révélations absolument ahurissante
je veux dire dans votre bouquin donc
d'abord castres où est le bâtard d'un
ancien soldat espagnol devenu un riche
propriétaire foncier proche de la united
food à celle des américains en faire un
grand résultat national du sucre mois la
paire de castro et et la mère de castro
en fait c'était la servante de ce type
là ce qui fait que lui très jeune il
souffre de ne pas être baptisé et les
gosses à l'école le traite de sale juif
et il se demande qui il est il dit est
ce que c'est moi qui ait assassiné le
fils de dieu enfin il est pris dans
cette espèce de folie oui parce qu'il
est il est d'abord il a il
une éducation jésuites il a été d'abord
chez les maristes et en prise avec les
jésuites
ce qui fait qu'ils se posent a demandé
la question est-ce que je suis maudit il
a surtout été abandonnée cacher comme il
était l'enfant illégitime un enfant
bâtard il a été caché chez un recruteur
des esclaves haïtiens à santiago de cuba
qui était noir qui parlaient français
qui parlait même pas sa langue
donc il a eu l'impression d'être
complètement rejetée c'est le syndrome
du bâtard et terrible chez lui donc il a
eu un besoin de reconnaissance sociale
extraordinaire ce qui explique cette
quête assoiffés et puis ces sentiments
ne pas être comme les autres d'être à
part il est à part il a vraiment le
sentiment d'être un personnage à part et
très vite il va cultiver cette posture
il va il va voir surtout un besoin de
revanche extraordinaire vis-à-vis de sa
propre famille qui va expliquer ce
besoin de séduire à l'extérieur de sa
propre famille alors là on découvre un
fidel castro absolument inconnu vecteur
de hitler oui parce que dans les années
30 40 étudier chez les et jésuites ça
veut dire c'est les pères jésuites qui a
à cuba à l'époque lui enseignait
le français d'autres cours et c'est
l'espagnol était tous franquiste donc
lui est fasciné par la phalange par par
l'idéologie franquiste et donc forcément
par l'idéologie hitlérienne et quand ils
arrivent à la fac il a effectivement il
arbore il exhibe avec castro lecteurs de
l'it l'air admirateur de mussolini dites
vous pareil enfin j'imagine pour les
pour les mêmes raisons et vous dites
d'ailleurs c'est tout à fait juste que
que la marge sur la havane ressemble
terriblement à la marche de mussolini
sur rome
au moment où il a pris le pouvoir quoi
tout à fait et d'ailleurs quand il crée
son premier mouvement qui s'appelle el
movimiento c'est un mouvement qui
ressemble énormément au mouvement
phalangistes ou les
les militants sont en tenue noire et
s'est entretenu un côté très uniforme
d'où la fascination aussi de l'uniforme
chez castro du tri de cette idée qu'on
ne peut prendre le pouvoir qu au bout du
fusil car la guerre en fait alors il est
aussi fascinée par napoléon iii et c'est
vrai qu'il a ce côté autocratique qu'on
a connu à notre un autre empereur en
france aussi malin que napoléon trouvait
alors étudiant en droit peu assidus un
peu gangster un peu lover c'est à dire
qui est quand même dans les coups un peu
tordue il aime bien les gonzesses
voilà faisant virer c'est pas très grave
mais et alors il se lance dans
l'activisme politique dans un mouvement
très anti communiste au départ il
navigue vraiment dans des mouvements
assez trouble il se cherche t il à il a
18 20 ans il se cherche mais il est
profondément anti communiste et jusqu'à
la prise de pouvoir
il se déclare anticommuniste et tous les
militants qui sont avec lui vont le
croire en train est finie c'est ça la
facilité terrible ce qui arrive pas
effectivement de se montrer
anticommunisme et qu'en fait vous dites
qu'il est recruté par le kgb
dès 1948 c'est à dire bien avant dix ans
avant en plus de dix ans avant sa prise
du pouvoir est en fait il le tient
secret c'est à dire son entrée dans le
kgb il le tient secrets ouais ça on l'a
on est dans du loup delhoum là on est
vraiment dans un roman d'espionnage
incroyable qui agace énormément les
spécialistes car c'est tous les
américains qui sont pas du tout contents
d'apprendre ça oui parce que tout le
monde pense qu'il est devenu communiste
après son accession au pouvoir on a le
temps à maera mais le drame c'est que
les américains en 57 finances le
mouvement de castro en pensant qu'il
anticommuniste il est déjà un
jean du kgb c'est ça qui est un peu
gênant et qui fait que beaucoup de gens
et pas mal d'historiens d'ailleurs du
castrisme n'osent pas en parler de ça et
surtout pas les américains qui sont un
peu gênés aux entournures c'est un peu
l'histoire de ben laden si vous voulez
qu'ils leur niveau qu'ils recrutent pour
entrer dans leur enquête gb alors ces
termes monsieur extraordinaire qui
s'appelle fabio grosbard mais son vrai
sens a lancé abrams m je vis un juif
polonais retrouve encore le le côté
fascination des juifs par pas de castro
ça serait aussi intéressant et cet homme
là était en fête à la tête d'un réseau
c'est un proche de staline il est à la
tête d'un réseau qui était financée par
un trafic de diamants or là on rentre
dans par moments ce jeu on se pince
parce qu on y croit même pas moi car
venant dans les découvertes que je
faisais je ne sais pas possible tu peux
pas écrire ça c'est trop énorme mais
pourtant c'est vrai et cet homme là se
ce réseau a même vendu des diamants aux
pertes de kennedy c'est ça qui est
facile car sacré trafiquants alors
ailleurs faut bien le dire et alors il
ya aussi les trois mois que castro passe
à new york pour une formation au sein du
kgb c'est ça c'est un des mystères de sa
vie c'est à dire qu'il ya un trou noir
ou un blanc vous préférez ou pendant
trois mois de ses commerces et comme
maître verges alors il ya à ce propos
moi ma thèse c'est qu'effectivement il a
été plus ou moins formés à ce moment là
aux techniques de manipulation et de
propagande ce qui explique son
incroyable habilité ce que c'est un
génie médiatique c'est à dire qu'on va
découvrir aussi son génie médiatique par
la suite mais il est fort mais à ce
moment là d'autres en ce moment commence
et il ya des thèses qui commencent à
poindre la du côté américain comme quoi
il aurait pu être aussi un agent de la
cia moi j'en parle pas un bon livre
parce que j'ai aucune problème
donc ça devient être incroyable c'est
compliqué mais en tous les cas son frère
cadet raul lui va à prague à un moment
donc c'est bien la preuve que les castro
aurait pu être formées tous les deux à
l'étranger selon les méthodes du kgb
alors moi j'ai rencontré l'agent
traitant des frères castro un du kgb
excellent nikolay leonov que j'ai
rencontré longuement à moscou pendant
plusieurs jours qui lui avait rencontré
raul castro dès 1953
c'est à dire six ans avant la prise de
pouvoir pour ceux qui connaissent un peu
l'histoire cubaine et il était déjà à
nageant communisme raul castro lui-même
le racontent ils étaient porteurs de
matériel de propagande marxiste et
cetera donc il était déjà formé à la
prise du pouvoir pour les parcs pour les
communistes
voilà alors cette infiltration de cuba
par des agents du kgb bien avant la
prise de pouvoir par castro fait que
quand il prend le pouvoir en 1959
l'assemblée législative et très
rapidement supprimée l'agriculture est
mise sous l'autorité de l'armée et donc
on assiste à un des passages les plus
rapides du du capitalisme au communisme
dans toute l'histoire du 20e siècle
tiens tiens c'est un tour de passe-passe
politique extraordinaire dans l'histoire
que peu de gens ont pu voir et nous on
avait tous était berné moi c'est à dire
que on nous a parlé du romantisme c'est
rama et cetera le robin des bois mais en
fait un mois après la prise du pouvoir
il y avait plus l'assemblée législative
et pour tous les politiques quand il ya
plus l'assemblée législative ça veut
dire qu'on est dans une dictature donc
rarement après c'était déjà une
dictature
les personnes le voyait justement alors
le type que castro remplace batista
qu'on a toujours considéré enfin je sais
la culture qu'on a eue nous enfin notre
génération a toujours été voué aux
gémonies
en fait j'ai un antique avait été élu au
suffrage universel lors totalement
lavage vous raconter une anecdote
explique moi ce qui m'est arrivé quand
je pencherais la cuba pour travailler
sur la jeunesse de castro cholet au
cimetière de banes en orienter tous les
parents de castro soit 10 ans devait
être enterrée j'aimerais les parents
castro j'ai trouvé les parents de
batista et en enquêtant sur les parents
de batista j'ai découvert qu'en fait
batista était un ami de la mère de
castro adacore oui ça change tout d'un
coup et tout d'un coup tout devient plus
compliqué que par exemple il a financé
le mariage il a participé à la dot du
mariage de castro assista en travaillant
sur lui je découvre qu'en 1940
cette espèce de dictateurs abjecte et
monstrueux à des cabinets a été lu en au
suffrage universel qu'il a promulgué une
constitution la plus moderne de toute
l'histoire de l'amérique du sud puisque
le droit de vote avait été accordé aux
femmes en 1940 cancer dont la france
voilà en france et de gaulle en 45 qui
donnent froid dans d'autres femmes et
batista le
homps troni chassé par castro l'avait
fait 55 ans avant avec une liberté de la
presse est un mec fréquentable il était
sans doute un petit peu ce que j'ai dit
c'est assez
il est devenu un dictateur à la mode car
arrive c'est à dire un type qui aime
bien les les métis les uniformes les
chercheurs qui brille et cetera un peu
la caricature du dictateur de à la
théorie au le dictateur de saint
domingue mais ça n'a rien à voir avec ce
qui va se passer après après ça va être
l'enfer
alors vous raconter dans votre bouquin
des anecdotes je conseille vraiment
solide c'est le lot de tous les mauvais
sens et l'attaquent de la moncada sert
en fait c'est raté parce que castro veut
pas mettre ses lunettes c'est ça parce
que les coq et non c'est à dire qu'il ya
ça aussi c'est des détails ce terrain
qu'on voit pas que la légende ne raconte
pas il se trouve que il pourra l'est de
la havane à santiago il ya 1000 km 1
donc c'est un long trajet il se rend
compte au mythe du trajet donc au bout
de 500 km qu'il a oublié ses lunettes
or il est très myope mais il ne peut pas
le montrer donc il va essayer à santa
clara de trouver des lunettes de
rechange rebelles vont pas être adapté à
sa vue ce qui fait que le matin à 5
heures du matin quand ils vont faire la
taille de la boucle de la moncada
eh bien les lunettes correspondent pas
il rate l'entrée c'est l'eau qui
aujourd'hui raccordés et les compagnons
le raconte mais comme la légende nous a
tellement vendu autre chose que ce genre
de détail est oubliée des açores il
prend des proportions énormes quand on
sait que ça a été un lien une casse ce
qui va devenir l'acte de naissance de la
république de la révolution cubaine est
en fait un frein au total tout ça parce
que castro n'a pas les bonnes lunettes
ce jour là et qu'il est coquet qui veut
qu'il veut pas mettre alors il ya aussi
une histoire des colombes lors de
l'investiture
donc en fait tout le monde se souvient
de cette image c'est l'investiture de
castro avec les colombes qui vole qui
vient de se poser et on s'est dit ça y
est quoi ca un signe du ciel ce typé et
béni fait pas du tout moi j'ai une
manière de travailler qui est très
simple je reprends beaucoup de gens mais
je fais aussi pas mal de travail en
bibliothèque et surtout à la vanne à la
bibliothèque de la havane en cherchant
des documents je suis tombé sur cette
fameuse photo du 8 janvier 59 où il fait
son grand discours qui a été reproduit
absolument dans toutes les télés du
monde on voit les colombes ce que vous
racontez et je trouve que je tombe sur
une photo en plan large
la télévision c'est un formidable outil
de propagande d'arrêt on le sait et lui
c'est le premier avec kennedy a utilisé
cette arme là dans l'histoire la
télévision est lui à côté de lui sur la
tribune on découvre un monsieur qui
entouré de deux pigeons blancs de colomb
qu'on appelle les palomas et il a en
fait des appeaux est en fait c'est un
colombophile versé un dresseur de
pigeons qui est qui voilà est-ce le
subterfuge a fonctionné et les cuba
l'ont pris pour un envoyé du ciel et
pour le messie c'est ça qu'il faut bien
comprendre il est devenu le messie donc
une popularité extraordinaire sur une
future robe de charlene des branchements
ordinaire on parle aussi de ses
conquêtes parce que c'est un homme à
femmes à étapes comme ava gardner gina
lollobrigida des actrices françaises
mais là bon ya pas trop les noms
pourquoi elles sont toujours là oui ils
sont toujours là et puis bon je voulais
pas rentrer dont je voulais pas faire un
livre uniquement de ragots il s'agit de
votre livre voilà et donc il ya bien sûr
il ya beaucoup de femmes françaises qui
ont été séduites par lui mais parce que
c'est un cetain c'est un sorcier
c'est un homme de karm exceptionnelle et
qui a surtout un l'art mais il ne commet
dirait il ne drague pas inutile
d'ailleurs généralement il a beaucoup
draguer aussi des journalistes
américaines
il faut toujours quand même que ça soit
rentable ça gigolo quoi des tas d un
gigolo d'état pas mal
alors vous pouvez aussi de l'assassinât
de kennedy donc vous dites vous en tous
les cas votre avis que l'assassinât
était organisée par la cia et les
groupes anticastristes de miami qui
croyaient en fait qu en assassinant
kennedy et en faisant porter le chapeau
à castro cuba serait libérée de castro
parce que en fait vous vous y croyez
vraiment à cette thèse vous en 63
kennedy est en train de préparer le
rapprochement avec castro ouais tout le
monde le sait à l'époque même le
directeur du nouvel observateur jean
dany j'en ai des gens vont ignorer leur
en émissaire parc est née d'un chez
fidel castro il participe donc il un
personnage très important à ce moment là
ils participent à cette tentative de
rapprochement
simplement pour faire pour prouver la
bossa bonne foi kennedy
va se débarrasser de tous les anti
castristes sur le territoire américain y
fait surtout une opération du fbi à et
violente qui va fermer un camp le camp
de pontchartrain où il ya les harvey
oswald où il ya tout un tas d'agents de
la cia et tous les anti castristes les
plus virulents qui devait assassiné
castro ces gens là se retrouve en prison
ou alors exclu expulsé et ils vont
monter une opération avec des gens de la
mafia pour effectivement assassiner
kennedy en essayant de faire porter le
chapeau
ça n'a pas du tout empêché ça n'a pas
marché puisque lee harvey oswald et
devait être la chèvre il devait être
l'agent castriste celui qu'on devait
photographié à cuba mais pourquoi les
agents de la sécurité parce qu'il est un
peu lee harvey oswald est une très
mauvaise chèvres il joue mal le jeu il
va taper à toutes les portes des
ambassades cubaine russe est ingrat mais
il est grillé c'est vrai quand l'écart
va pas fait porter le chapeau à castres
aux examens il a rien à voir avec cette
histoire
voilà un ya beaucoup de gens qui ont
porté le chapeau alors vous évoquez
également la possibilité de la
culpabilité de fidel castro dans la mort
du président socialiste chilien salvador
allende lors du coup d'état de 1973
vous dites il n'a pas été abattu en fait
par des soldats chiliens milles par des
services spéciaux cubain pour en faire
un martyr de la cause révolutionnaire
c'est à dire un che guevara en costume
trois pièces dites vous ouais j'ai dit
que c'était une rumeur général circulent
aujourd'hui au chili moi je n'ai
absolument aucune preuve je ne dors pas
c'était là un tout c'est possible
simplement que politiquement allende
était le symbole de la voie démocratique
au social celui ci acceptait d'aller
devant le suffrage universel et devant
les urnes castro n'a jamais fait de la
guerre il ya la révolution que je dis
c'est que politiquement historiquement
un moment donné allende était entouré de
d'un agent castriste que sa propre
famille était un petit peu tenu je
dirais par des agents de la sécurité
cubaine à cette époque là puisque sa
fille béatrice était mariée à un agent
cubain et qui va d'ailleurs se suicider
à cuba quelques temps plus tard la soeur
d'alien des se suicident aussi à cuba
quelques temps plus tard c'est un
dossier très troublant qui commence à me
faire aux jets les chiliens mais moi je
n'ai jamais dit c'est une piste que vous
lever d'un gastro est elle responsable
de ça alors il ya aussi vous pensez
qu'ils pourraient être aussi dans
l'assassinât de che guevara
là il aurait agi pour le compte des
soviétiques parce que che guevara serait
devenu trop trop encombrant pour les
russes avec à cette époque là au milieu
des années 60
guevara continue lui à être un
internationaliste et à croire la
révolution mondiale
il va se tourner vers mao castro lui est
financé par les russes il a besoin que
son pays tourne il a besoin d'argent
soviétique
il n'a pas le choix il faut qu'ils
restent donc quelque part le che a trahi
la grosse cubaine ouais donc il devient
un personnage un peu encombrant qu'on
voit qu'on va envoyer dans une espèce de
voies de garage on va dire en bolivie où
il va aller lui-même c'est à dire que là
aussi ce n'est pas castro qui envoie
guevara à la mort c'est un mélange c'est
à dire que guevara lui-même c'est qu'au
fond son histoire est finie et comme
c'est quelqu'un qui est obsédé par le
martyrologe on retrouve tout ça dans la
dans l'idéologie guévariste physiologie
des guérés des guérilleros très christie
c'est très christie quand même aux côtés
martyrologe qu'on retrouve aujourd'hui
chez certains islamistes etc etc
c'est un peu les mêmes discours
controverse simplement guevara lui a
fait rêver alors face à ce personnage de
castro les intellectuels français sont
envoûtés un petit peu comme vous c'est
un trafic vous l'étiez alors jean paul
sartre et simone de beauvoir son rythme
en ensorcelé manipulé par par castro il
se fout complètement de leur gueule quoi
ah oui mais d'ailleurs j'ai rencontré
l'interprète de castres au 1t poc
l'acquis donc suivait les interviews les
intellectuels français et lui me raconte
clairement que à chaque fois c'était un
jeu pour lui d'arriver à les berner de
sa muse il a fait croire
il a fait croire des intellectuels
français qu'on pouvait faire pousser des
fraises dans le désert et à l'actuel
français le croyait mais il avait une
technique très efficace que ça il les
faisait réver leur parlant de la
révolution française ce qui connaît la
révolution française mieux que les
autres souches j'essaye et ça continue
ici mal c'était pas ça qui va leur
expliquer alors ça ferait beau voir
évidemment le soleil à notre ami bernard
kouchner qui dans les années 60
participa aux brigades rural bien sûr il
a coupé la can comme beaucoup de gens
cette époque là ce qui était d'ailleurs
une d'un point de vue de l'efficacité de
la productivité une vraie catastrophe
ce que des études ont été faites par des
économistes sont les intellectuels
allait couper la canne c'était une vraie
catastrophe à air qui tenait absolument
pas les cadences évidemment le la
récolte de canne à sucre était une
catastrophe absolue alors il ya sap il
ya aussi le baiser danielle mitterrand
sur le perron de l'élysée en 95 quand
même plus grave parce que tu es la femme
du président de la république française
est aujourd'hui encore castro arrive à
trouver quand même de plus en plus
rarement mais des supports en france il
n'y as you ramoné qu'est le patron du
monde diplomatique dirigeants d'attac ya
gérard depardieu qui est très ami avec
fidel castro fait chercher du pétrole un
cubage facile à trouver mais en tous les
cas il a apporté sa caution à ce
dictateur depardieu c'est un peu à part
il ya un côté aventurier un peu à la
tête du client il mails quand il y va
ferrer a t-il mais par contre les autres
c'est vraiment lié à une idéologie
tiers-mondiste c'est à dire à partir de
mon et du tiers-monde qu'on soit un
dictateur ou pas c'est quand même bien
en a beau on peut imprimer son peuple
c'est pas grave du moment qu'on est
content les américains l'essentiel c'est
d'être contre les américains et castro
le problème c'est qu'il opprime son
peuple et il essaye d'être du côté des
opprimés ce qui est difficile c'est
quand on est soi-même un oppresseur
comment être du côté des opprimés
les intellectuels tiers-mondiste
aujourd'hui en france qui justement
critiquent le fait qu'on puisse ne pas
soutenir le régime castriste aujourd'hui
devrait quand même se poser ce genre de
questions alors vous faites aussi des
révélations serge raffy sur la vraie
fausse interview de castro par patrick
poivre d'arvor que j'avais révélé l
époque à la télévision dans double jeu
en fait c'est beaucoup plus simple que
tout ce qu'on avait cru à l'époque c'est
à dire qu'en fait bouygues pour
faciliter la construction d'un hôtel à
cuba dit finalement on va vous envoyer
poivre d'arvor qui va faire une très
belle interview de fidel castro voilà
comme ça vous serez gentil avec nous
vous n'aurez la fabrication de l'hôtel
le problème c'est que vous faites un
sujet vous faites un sujet avec un
copain ou sur l'avenue tout et ce sujet
sur sur cuba vous le vendez à la
sainteté afin d'en veut pas on comprend
pourquoi vous le vendez à la 5 et en
fait castro est furieux parce que pour
lui à pala 5 était enfin pour lui c'est
la télévision française
donc il met tout le monde dans le même
sac il est furieux du sujet que vous
avez fait est vendu à la 5 et donc il
fait la gueule à poivre d'arvor qui en
fait venez lui pour faire un sujet et
donc tf1 est privé de scoop
ce qui amène poivre d'arvor avec son ami
régis faucon à bricoler un petit peu
l'interview qu'ils ont fait de castro
c'est ça l'histoire c'est ça je pense
que poivre d'arvor lui n'était pas au
courant du tout il a été envoyé faire un
faire une grande interview de castro
c'est toujours bon enfant elles jouaient
sur moi le premier je leur écris aussi
donc là-dessus il n'y a aucune espèce
d'ambiguïté
mais par contre les coulisses beaucoup
plus compliqué et c'est vrai qu'à ce
moment-là bouygues négocier des gros
chantiers d'hôtels à varadero au tout le
monde connaît varadero aujourd'hui
beaucoup d'hôtels ont été construit par
bouygues et castro évidemment on va pas
être très content alors castro il va
rester là jusqu'à quand on bat jusqu'à
la fin il a tout prévu
c'est à dire que s'il a prévu de
s'échapper de l'île en un clin d'oeil
c'est comme si on est face à un homme
qui ce qui est un prophète
messi est un missionnaire il est là il
pense qu il fait le bien il est quand
même en un cul que ce qui est sa mission
est utile pour leur peuple qu'ils
pensent toujours qu'ils représentent la
vérité la juge
et c'est contre le monde entier qui lui
est mauvais on retombe toujours sur ses
espèces de totalitarisme c'est un
mystique c'est un jésuite
donc il ne partira pas il partira que si
la limite biologique
ouais de son parcours arrivera un jour
où l'autre est alors oui mais c'est la
semaine on a vu revenir sur le devant de
la scène son frère raul
on sait plus du tout où il était passé
on l'a vu revenir donc ça veut dire
qu'après castro on peut se taper raul
encore constitutionnellement il est le
vice président du conseil d'état et donc
la constitution a prévu qu'en cas de les
disparitions des missions de fidel
castro
c'est le vice président en l'occurrence
c'est raul castro le clan donc il
prendra le pouvoir mais alors est ce que
lui a les capacités de tenir les rênes
de la même manière que son frère aîné ça
c'est là le grand mystère
voilà serge raffy ça s'appelle castoldi
belle
je suis assez finement
il faut
le prendre
cobra